اعلنت الشرطه الالمانيه انتهاء واقعه
احتجازي رهائن في وسط مدينه جريسدن شرقي
البلاد والقاء القبض على الجاني ونجاه
المحتجزين دون اصابته كما قالت الشرطه
انها عثرت على جثه امراه في مبنى سكني
بمنطقه التي شهدت عمليه الاحتجاز وكان
المجتمع به احتجزرها الى داخل مركز التسوق
التماركه جاليري وسط مدينه
الشرطه اثر ذلك
وسوق الكريسماس وقيدت حركه المرور وسطها
المدينه
معنا من برلين مراسله جزيره اسد الله صاوي
اسد الله بعد ان انتهت هذه العمليه بحسب
بيان الشرطه ما الذي تتكشف حتى الان
نعم عبد القادر لم تكشف الشرطه حتى الان
عن هويه المحتجز ولا عن دوافع للقيام بهذا
ما هو مؤكد حتى الان هو انه وجدت امراه
مقتوله يقال انها همم
هذا محتجز الراهن بانها امه بعض المصادر
قالت كذا كذلك هذا المحتجز قامه لمده ساعه
تقريبا باحتجاز رهائن في داخل متجر في وسط
مدينه همم
متجر همم
سلم نفسه بعدما ااه تمت عمليه التواصل بين
هو بين الشرطه على مدار الساعه او اكثر
همم لم يكشف بعد عن تفاصيل همم ما تم ولا
عن الدوافع ولا عن هويه هذا الشخص او
ارتباطه باي جهات معينه نحن في انتظار
بيانات اكثر من الشرطه الالمانيه بهذه
الصداقه كيف تبعت وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه
هذا
حادثه في الترجيح بين الدوافع ان كانت
الجنائيه او همم سياسيه حتى الان اسد الله
همم وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه تتعامل مع
الامر بمهنيه همم بحث بمعنى انتظار
البيانات الرسميه قبل اصدار اي احكام ولكن
عطفا على هذا يجب قوله ان الاعصاب نوعا ما
مشدوده في المانيا هذه الايام منذ الكشف
يوم الاربعاء الماضي عن همم محاوله قلب
نظام الحكم تماما في المانيا التخلص من
الدوله الالمانيه بمفهومها الحديث
بمفهومها الحاليه من قبل ما يعرف بتنظيم
مواطن الرائق يجب هنا الاشاره ايضا الى
اندرسن همم
اقصى شرق المانيا قرب الحدود البولنديه
والتشيكيه هي معروفه بانها ناقل الجماعات
اليمين المتطرف همم هي معقل حركه جديده
مثلا وهي ايضا همم من همم المعقل الرئيسيه
لتنظيم مواطني همم
الشرطه في الايام الاخيره قالت ان اا
تنظيم مواطني الرايخ كان همم يعني يتحصل
على كم كبير من الاسلحه من الجيش الالماني
ذاته وان عدد من اعضاء التنظيم هم ضباط
سابقون وان هناك شكوك بان همم يعني عدد من
الضباط الحاليين او عناصر الجيش الالمانيه
الحالي ايضا هم من اعضاء تنظيم مواطن كل
هذه يخلق حاله من التوتر عموما عندما يسمع
اي صوت في في اي مدينه فما بالك الحديث عن
قتل امراه واحتجاز
رهائن وعمليه للشرطه واغلاق وسط مدينه
كبيره مثل همم
مدينه معروفه بانها باقل من معاقل اليمين
المتطرف في المانيا سنعود لك اسد الله على
صدور بيان رسمي هذه العمليه او ظهور جديد
في هذه العمليه شكرا لك اسد الله الصاوي
كنت معنا من برلين